I guess it's been a while since we've
met mate I guess my confession is it's
been three years since my last periodic
video as you know I got a new job a
number of years ago and the job was to
be the director of this new development
this carbon neutral laboratory that we
built that we're building in Nottingham
and much of my time over the last three
years has actually been devoted to
building and overseeing and actually
breathing to life the project so this
building is a an opportunity for us to
learn how to do science how to do
chemistry in a fundamentally different
way in a way that allows us to achieve
the goals that we want to achieve but
without creating as much damage and
without creating such a large carbon
footprint well when you build a building
typically you build it out of things
like concrete and steel what many people
don't understand about using concrete
and steel is if it costs a lot of energy
to make the concrete and make the steel
so what we've done is that we've built
our building out of sustainable
materials quite a lot of wood which you
can see here got a lot of natural
materials like clays and as you can see
a grass roof on the top of our building
we're now starting to put instruments
inside there's no science going on in
this building yet but I can show you
some of the spaces and I can show you
where my group will be where my office
will be just as a sneaky preview so that
you can whet your appetite and perhaps
come back and look a little bit later
there's been a huge amount of work and
it's not just my work as clearly I'm not
a builder we've had a team of sometimes
up to a hundred people working here and
some of the best craftsmen that you
could ever imagine
so I'm this is my new office as you can
see it's not an office yet we've got
furniture on the floor and the odd
cardboard box actually my new role is
director of this this facility allows me
to focus more on my research so my
research group is growing and my
research group will move into the
building as well and my research group
are incredibly excited about moving into
a building you know how many people in
the world have made a molecule are not
considered what the impact of the SOT
the side products or the waste products
of their process are and essentially
we've got to consider all aspects all of
the atoms that go into our synthesis to
make sure that we know the end fate of
the atoms at the end so as we go up
these steps so if you take a look up to
the ceiling you'll see these really cool
translucent photovoltaics so they're
actually generating currents and
and actually allowing some natural light
to come through as well so we're
generating electric and lighting at the
same time so and we're upstairs in the
building now on the research level all
of our labs are upstairs I like this
space so you know because it allows you
to come and engage in the environment
and think about what's going on out
there and I'd actually relax from your
science for a few moments so actually
what we're going to do with this space
is put some chairs in and put some
whiteboard spaces so that they can
actually think and create about science
and actually use this space productively
so the reason we're here now though is
because it's actually sort of the
entranceway to my lab so the new lab
that my group will move into in the next
three or four weeks time it's called lab
3 it doesn't have a name as yet because
as I said this project is not finished
yet and we're on we're rapidly on the
way to getting there so this laboratory
I suppose is our first inspection looks
just like an old-fashioned lab you know
we got benches along the walls we've got
fume cupboards but if you take a look up
towards the roof in this laboratory
you'll see that the the roof space is
really quite expansive you can actually
see all of the supply and extract ducts
you can see the delivery of all of the
materials that you need to do your
science a few cupboards look pretty much
conventional and in fact they are quite
conventional they're sort of more
elaborate fume cupboards because they
give us side panels that we can move so
that we can use safety features which
are not on all fume cupboards but I
suppose the key innovation is actually
in the plant rooms upstairs
because the plant which runs our fume
cupboards uses a much much smaller
amount of energy so that we can provide
the safe environment to do science
without costing too much in terms of
energy and therefore additional carbon
it's probably one of the most efficient
laboratories in the world it's the first
of its type I'm not going to tell you
about the technical aspects because it's
a boring match up which will last an
hour it's very very efficient it uses
approximately 1/3 of the energy of a
traditional laboratory
million pound building was completely
destroyed by fire the building wasn't
complete it wasn't a building it was
still in some ends census a pile of wood
and an accident happened I was actually
on holiday in in North Norfolk in an
area where there's no phone signal and
no internet hopefully on a digital detox
I managed to get a text message at about
11 o'clock in the evening and yeah the
the news was delivered and yeah ruined
the holiday and caused the dramatic
change in the following two years but
you know the building burnt down and
it's less than two years later we've
rebuilt it it's now complete it now has
all of its fire systems armed protecting
it and we're getting excited about
moving into new signs so this is what's
called our winter garden it's an amazing
space it's for us to have networking
idea generation small conferences if you
come here you can see the most amazing
optical illusion which you'll never see
on a camera so where the camera is if
you look over the edge of the balcony if
you have a brain connected to the eye or
the lens your brain starts playing a
trick with you PC because the glass wall
to the right and the wooden wall to the
left are both on a really unusual
incline so if you then focus on the
stairway which is halfway along this
room it looks like the whole thing's
falling over it's really really
fantastic it makes people quite get in
quite wobbly and in fact made our
builders panic they went away and got
all sorts of levels and and surveyed the
building to make sure that they built it
straight so what we've done here in
Nottingham is we've run an experiment
and that experiment has been truly truly
multidisciplinary it's involved chemists
it's involved architects it's involve
construction people it's involve people
from industries that I would never have
ever dreamt of and as I said it really
is an experiment it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to try
and do science in a fundamentally better
way Neil and he was going to load it and
then we're going to drop the hammer it
big O'Neil we're going to wear secondary
goggles so here's my safety goggles
which I'm going to put on top
don't we look good